Determining the optimal transcription factor
binding site can be pretty difficult.
And usually has to be determined empirically. What that means, is,
we normally have to go to the lab to figure it
out. But that's not always an easy thing to do. And sometimes,
it's a little faster to do what we call sequence comparisons,
or sequence alignments. What this means is instead of going into
the lab I am going to take, let's say 5 or
6 different individuals and I am going to take the transcription factor
binding inside sequence for this person and that person
and that person and that person and I am going to
line them all up together, one on top of the
other. For instance I have these 6 sequences right here,
hypothetically speaking off course from 6 different individuals. And
when you line them all up like this, hopefully what
you notice first off is that there are very few
differences in the overall sequences. But at any given position,
you can see that there's a dominant nucleotide
in that column. We call this the consensus,
or the agreement, right, because most of the
letters in that column are one letter or another.
So what I want you to try to do right now is looking at these six
sequence alignments, tell me what you think the
consensus sequence is for this transcription factor binding site.